am schwersten trifft eigentlich die
Verantwortung die CDU die über lange
Zeit hinweg Kernthemen die den
konservativen zugeordnet werden
vernachlässigt hat und Platz gelassen
hat das andere sich an diesen Themen
abarbeiten das ist als wichtiges ist aus
meiner Sicht die Frage des Euros das war
damals die Gründung der AFD die Frage
der Geldwertstabilität die Frage auch
das Wohlstandes im Lande wenn sie sich
die Gründerväter und Mütter angucken die
alle nicht ja bei der AFD sind die
hatten das Thema mit dem Euro das war
auch damals völlig berechtigt diese
Frage zu stellen nach der
Finanzmarktkrise und das zweite Thema
ist Migration und zwar mit dem was da
noch dran hängt nämlich eine oft
mangelhaften Integration das bedeutet
wieder ruhestandsgefährdung im Bereich
der sozialen Sicherungssysteme wenn mehr
Leute raus kriegen als rein zahlen und
das bedeutet aber auch eine
Verschlechterung beim Thema Ordnung und
Sicherheit auch nimmt konservativen
Kernthema